Hey guys.
Welcome back.
Today, we're going to be working
on a problem that asks
you to find the PMF of a
function of a random variable.
So let's just jump right in.
The problem statement gives
you the PMF for a random
variable called x.
So we're told that there's this
random variable x that
takes on values minus 3, minus
2, minus 1, 1, 2, and 3.
And for each of those values,
the probability mass lying
over that value is given
by this formula, x
squared over a.
Now I didn't write it here to
save room, but we're also told
that a is a real number that
is greater than 0.
And we're told that the
probability of x taking on any
value outside of the set is 0.
Now we're asked to do two
things in the problem.
First is to find the value
of the parameter a.
And that's sort of a natural
question to ask, because if
you think about it, the PMF
isn't fully specified.
And in fact, if you plug in the
wrong number for a, you
actually won't get
a valid PMF.
So we'll explore that idea
in the first part.
And then the second part, you're
given a new random
variable called z.
And z happens to be
a function of x.
In fact, it's equal
to x squared.
And then you're asked
to compute that PMF.
So this problem is a good
practice problem.
I think, at this point, you
guys are sort of newly
acquainted with the
idea of a PMF, or
probability mass function.
So this problem will hopefully
help you get more familiar
with that concept and how
to manipulate PMFs.
And by the way, just to make
sure we're all on the same
page, what does a PMF
really tell you?
So p sub X, where this is
a capital X, because the
convention in this class
is to use capital
letters for random variables.
So p X of k, this is defined
to be the probability that
your random variable X takes
on a value of k.
So essentially, this says--
and this is just some number.
So in our particular case,
this would be equal to k
squared over a.
And how you can interpret
this is this px guy is
sort of like a machine.
He takes in some value that
your random variable could
take on, and then he spits out
the amount of probability mass
lying over that value.
OK.
So now that we've done that
quick recap, let's get back to
the first part of the problem.
So we have this formula for
px of x, and we need
to solve for a.
So in order to do that, we're
going to use one of our axioms
of probability to set
up an equation.
And then we can solve
precisely for a.
So namely, we know that every
PMF must sum to 1.
And so essentially, if you sum
this guy over all possible
values of x, you should get a 1,
and that equation will let
us solve for a.
So let's do that.
Summation over x of px of x.
So here, essentially
you're only summing
over these six values.
So this is equal to px of minus
3, plus px of minus 2,
plus px of minus 1, et cetera.
Oops. px of 2 plus px of 3.
OK.
And again, like the
interpretation as we said,
this number here should be
interpreted as the amount of
probability mass lying
over minus 3.
And to help you visualize this,
actually, before we go
further with the computation,
let's actually plot this PMF.
So the amount of probability
mass lying over minus 3, the
way we figure that out is we
take minus 3 and we plug it
into this formula up here.
So you get 9/a.
Now you can do this
for minus 2.
You've got 4/a, looking
at the formula.
For 1, you get 1/a.
And of course, this graph, it's
the mirror image over 0,
because of the symmetry.
So hopefully this little
visualization helps you
understand what I'm
talking about.
And now we can just read
these values off of the
plot we just made.
So we know px minus 3
is equal to px of 3.
So we can go ahead and just
take 2 times 9/a.
Similarly, we get 2 times 4/a,
and then plus 2 times 1/a.
So now it's just a question
of algebra.
So simplifying this, you're
going to get 18 plus 8 plus 2,
divided by a.
And this gives you 28/a.
And as I argued before, you
know that if you sum a PMF
over all possible values,
you must get 1.
So this is equal to 1, which
of course implies that a is
equal to 28.
So what we've shown here is that
you actually don't have a
choice for what value
a can take on.
It must take on 28.
And in fact, if you plug in
any other value than 28 in
here, you actually are not going
to have a valid PMF,
because it's not going
to sum to 1.
OK.
So I'm going to write my answer
here, and then erase to
give myself more room for part